hidden under a jacket and rushed into a
courtroom shrouded in secrecy Evan
gershkovic pleaded not guilty before a
Russian judge to charges of being a spy
my name Evan was taken away from here
with a decision to hold him in custody
said his lawyer who wasn't allowed in
the room
is an accredited American journalist in
Russia working for the Wall Street
Journal arrested in the city of
yaketerenberg by Russia's secret service
for what the country's defense Ministry
says were actions not related to
journalism
referring to a statement a legend he was
stealing secrets for the U.S government
The Wall Street Journal vehemently
denies the allegations this Espionage
charges are ridiculous it is not safe at
this time to be in Russia the reporter
had recently been covering Russian's
attitude towards the war and its
economic impact
this political strategist was
interviewed by gershowitz in
yaketerenberg and says they never
discussed the military complex adding he
wasn't an enemy of Russia the targeting
of American citizens by the Russian
government is absolutely completely
unacceptable accusations of Espionage
are not unheard of in Russia but for
journalists it's rare Nick danieloff the
man in the glasses in this photo was the
last to be detained for spying in 1986
and was released in a prisoner swap
something the state department isn't
discussing this early in the process our
number one priority continues to be
seeking Consular access so we can meet
with this individual this arrest comes
amid escalating tensions between Russia
and the U.S us and could further isolate
Vladimir Putin and it shows just how
fearful the Kremlin may be of Journalism
that isn't controlled by the state
Reggie Global News Washington